welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Voss and I know I know Spider-Man across
the spider-verse included Mal's roommate
Genki Lee playing the real life upcoming
Spider-Man 2 game it's one of 50
additional details in Easter eggs I did
not include in my massive breakdown of
the film that I am now going to share
with you after you get another free
watch of this amazing film spoiler
morning and let's do this one last time
real quick I did break down the 2018
film for dozens of new details and I
hosted a live stream of across the
spider-verse on the Deep dive Channel
subscribe and support us with a Miles
Morales Multiverse dive shirt at nerd
right that shop in case you missed it
new rockstars isn't just one channel
anymore it's three earlier this year we
launched the Deep dive where I dig into
the deeper meaning behind everything you
love and our newest channel the break
room is where all of your nerdy friends
are gonna hang out online it's also the
new home for inside Marvel and all of
our reactions to the latest trailers TV
shows and movies we've got so many cool
videos planned so head on over and
subscribe and while you're at it don't
forget to subscribe to the new
Rockstar's main Channel and the Deep
dive okay the opening frames of the film
actually have a red graffiti word cough
flash in the lower right corner this is
a running joke with Lord and Miller film
since 22 Jump Street when a cough was
audible in the opening seconds and they
added a cough to the 2018 into the
spider-verse film if you listen closely
detail number two a dolphin sound effect
can be heard over the Lord Miller logo
another running joke from these guys
from Clone High when they put that sound
effect and everything the Lego Movie and
yes the opening cards of the 2018
spider-verse film detail three one of
the shirts Earth 65 Peter wears along
with that Halloween lizard costume is
the same Polo that Peter Parker wears in
the 90s animated series detail 4. in
Miles recap he talks about a baby powder
sponsorship deal which is a callback to
Peter B Parker in the 2018 film
recommending baby powder in the suit and
we see Miles YouTube apology video it
gets 11 million views yet somehow 69
million down votes 69 and this comment I
heard it was made from actual babies
though for real detail 5. in Miles
fantasy when he reveals himself to his
parents I love how they throw the couch
in the air and it never comes back down
because it's a fantasy 2006 bagels are
everywhere in this movie reflecting
their importance to the spot's origin
from the 2018 movie that amazing moment
and of course the everything everywhere
all at once everything bagel symbol but
bagels are also in the pastry case in
the bodega a bagel also follows miles
and jonathanone through a portal and in
the spider Society cafeteria a lot of
people are eating bagels pizza number
seven in the ATM the 100 bills are not
Benjamin Franklin's I now realize they
are actually Alan Hawkins Sony's
animation supervisor diesel eight miles
dad was named Jeff Davis in the 2018
movie and in the comics but if you look
at his badge in this movie they've
updated his name to Jeff Morales meaning
he took his wife's surname now the
comics go into why Jeff and Rio decide
to give miles Rio's surname of Morales
basically Jeff didn't want miles to have
his father's last name win miles is late
Jeff says I see bubbles on the phone
referring to the three dots on the text
feed but it's also literally the soap
suds that miles is covered in In This
Moment detail 10 when miles returns to
his dorm room he waits for pigeons to
fly past like a jogger waiting for
traffic at an intersection showing how
miles has learned turned after running
into pigeons and sticking to all of them
in the first movie detail 11 yes Genki
Lee is playing the Spider-Man 2 upcoming
video game when miles enters the room
that lucky kid
is a poster for soccer player kyung
minson known for doing a Spider-Man
celebration whenever he scores he's also
apparently friends with Tom Holland 13
miles jokes about buying two cakes
that's kind of a life hack but buying
two cakes later screws him over because
he can't flip with both of them in his
hands just a fun way of showing Miles
trying to juggle two parts of his life
14. when Jeff follows miles in spots the
alchemics site he faces the leap of
faith into a portal but then he washes
out and takes the stairs just like miles
initially did with his jump test in the
2018 film 15. The Spot reveals that the
number 42 spider came from an alternate
Dimension Earth 42. I love how they
foreshadowed this in the first movie by
having the spider glitch in that movie
because the spider was in the wrong
reality 16. for the spot's design bfx
supervisor Mike Lasker said that as the
spot evolves throughout the movie his
Ink Spots get more and more active and
busier and they have just more
personality as they pop off his body 17.
when miles Swings with Gwen he says
[Music]
good money to see that he says a vampire
good guy I paid good money to see that
Amanda knocked you morbius good guy
vampire that Sony hoped we'd pay good
money to see twice 18. miles tells my
favorite character in the movie to stop
licking the window and it's kind of a
callback to when he put his mouth on
Aaron's window back in 2018 19. when we
first see the spot's apartment beneath
that everything overall at once
reference billboard is a sign
1917-1610616 1610 miles Universe 616 the
main Marvel Universe 1917 I know maybe
not to the same menace movie 20. and my
favorite shot of the movie Gwen walks
upside down on that Bank building and
the sunset flare disappears and then
reappears upon the rotation it's so
beautifully designed everything in the
scene 21 another detail here Gwen and
Miles sit upside down by whipping the
underside of the overhang and then as
they sit their hands and legs must be
sticky they got sticky butts 22 as they
hang upside down you can see gravity
tugging their eyebrows their cheeks and
their foreheads upward 23 on the way to
jonathanone's place there is a sign of
the background soda it's a generic brand
24 pavita prabhakar is acrobatic
movement and the way he flattens his
feet as he moves is based on and I'm
gonna mispronounce this I'm so sorry
kalari payatu it's a 2 000 year old
martial art from the Indian region of
Kerala one of the oldest known martial
arts still practiced in the present day
on Earth 25. I had already talked about
how Hobie Brown's Body was animated with
a lower frame rate but it's actually
different parts of his body like his
body was animated on threes with his
best slightly offset his guitar is
animated on fours so that we see each
individual part of him strumming it as a
rock star pose and its General outline
is actually animated on twos the way
miles was at the beginning of the 2018
film so they separated different parts
of his body for an overall anarchic punk
rock aesthetic June is when summer heats
up and if you want to keep cool minimize
your time in the kitchen with Factor
factors fresh never frozen meals already
in two minutes so you can spend time not
standing in front of a hot stove when
it's 80 degrees out factor is America's
number one ready to eat meal kit you've
heard me talk about hellofresh but
factor is owned by hellofresh and I use
both of them my life is twice as easy
twice as tasty Factor lets me skip
shopping chopping and prepping and
cleaning plus Factor has more than 34
weekly options plus over 45 add-ons that
include breakfast items like bacon and
cheddar egg bites and potato bacon and
egg breakfast Skillets hassle-free bacon
in the mail it's a dream come true and
now Factor offers Gourmet plus meals as
part of your weekly options Gourmet
sides include premium produce like
broccoli and broccolini that perfectly
complement your Gourmet protein which
can be serpent syrup that's shrimp and
salmon or serpenter that's shrimp and
steak and I can tell you from personal
experience that even after reheating the
steak it's so good it's not dry it's not
tough It's just good this month I got
creamy Parmesan Chicken it was so oh
yummy so head on over to factor75.com or
click the link below and use the code
rockstars50 to get 50 off your first
Factor box once again that's
factor75.com and use code rockstars 50
to get 50 off your first Factor box 26
in Nueva York beside the PS4 Spidey is
the Green Goblin from the 1982
Spider-Man Atari game 27 as Hobie steals
stuff from around Miguel's lab in the
background Miguel is actually building
his red and white 2099 suit from the
game 28 when miles explains Canon
defense in the notes for the Venom event
one of the wedges is actually Toby
Maguire Peter Parker when he pulled the
Symbiote off himself in the 2007 film 29
Canadian Spider-Woman according to
production designer Patrick O'Keefe they
got her look from the 1972 Summit Series
hockey jersey 30. one of the spideys who
chases miles is the Spider-Man popsicle
that we saw at the beginning of the
first movie 31 in that cafeteria they
also serve Miguel O'Hara branded
hamburgers 32 1967 Spider-Man tries to
grab Miles but he misses him why because
67 Spidey is in 2D animation and he
flies right past him 33 composer retro
Boomin cameos as one of the spider
people there's nowhere to run
my bad everybody there was somewhere to
run 34 also some of the spideys are
based on Vintage Mexican wrestler toys
35 the 90s animated Sinister Six in the
training room we already talked about
but the doc Ox says hello Peter which is
audio of Alfred Molina's doc hawk in
Spider-Man no way home 36 on the train
as it flies towards the moon miles
glitches and for a frame you can see its
DIY suit from the first movie bought
from Stan Lee's costume shop 37 when
miles swings through Earth 42 there are
some Sinister Six cartel red flags if
you look closely signs for vulture
Telecom and Electro 2G cell service and
then on the rooftop later signs for
Hammerhead and scorpo which might be an
alternate universe Oz Corp 38 WWE's
alternate M M's also have the colors
reversed from the normal colors of the
regular versus peanut ones 39 instead of
forever 21. there's never 21. how low is
the life expectancy of this place 40
when Peter B Parker puts Mayday to sleep
she wears spider ham pajamas 41 when
Gwen goes yep B Parker her wrist Gadget
reads 616b A retcon for the first movie
that labeled his Universe just 616
because they don't want to say it is the
main 616. 42 miles coat and Hoodie in
Earth 42 are green and purple instead of
red and blue from a 1610 green and
purple being the color of Miles Aura in
the 2018 film right before Peter saw the
red and blue in him and altered his life
trajectory also important to note that
Aaron's apartment is red in blue which
leads to my theory that I talked about
another video that these guys might
actually be good guys 43 Rio has green
eyes in Earth 42 instead of her normal
Brown could just be the lighting of this
room 44 there's also a sketch of the
prowler claw in Earth 42 miles bedroom
and 45 miles poster above his bed is
oshami on a green background instead of
Sashimi on red as it is in his bedroom
in 1610 46 Rio asks do you website of
your coolito which is Spanish for little
butt and Miles says I had a nightmare
about that once but no and since this is
connected to the Multiverse logic of the
MCU there was that Multiverse of Madness
dream walking rule might apply here in
which dreams are technically you period
into your life into your alternate
universe self and both America Chavez
and MCU Peter Parker speculating about
alternate Spider-Man maybe shooting webs
out of their butts so there is one out
there that does this 47. on the roof
Aaron's phone lights up as he side eyes
miles a detail showing at 42 miles that
texted him that he was on his way 48 in
the 2018 film we saw miles going from
having his shoes untied two tying issues
but in the movie to show his Evolution
his maturity but now when he's tied up
to Aaron's punching bag he's back to his
shoes being untied 49 while 16 10 miles
famously wears Air Jordan Ones with the
red and white colors and the black
swoosh for 42 miles wears Nike Airs with
ultimate black colors and 50 when Gwen
has her emotional speech with her dad
the mood ring watercolor background
Rains Down in these specific Stripes
blue pink white pink and blue which
makes the transgender flag also on her
dad's uniform his patch shows the trans
flag and I already mentioned on Gwen's
room is the protect trans kid sign I'm
not telling you what to think I'm just
saying these animators use color in this
really cool way to show how difficult it
can be for kids to reveal themselves to
their parents and now for all these kids
out there you're not alone hey a
reminder to subscribe to our new channel
the Deep dive if you can support us by
grabbing some merch at nerdright.shop
follow me on Instagram and Twitter at
eavos follow new rockstars And subscribe
to new rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]